الكشف عن اعترافات قاتله الوليد الغريبي
وموعد محاكمتها وزاره العدل الامريكيه
وشركه اسلحه تقدم عرضا لاوكرانيا الطائره
بالدولار واحد هذه الاخبار وغيرها نقولها
لكم من قناه العربيه اهلا بكم
بعد ما انتهت الشرطه من التحقيقات كافه
اكد عم المبدعه المغدور به في امريكا
ستمثل امام المحكمه في مدينه فيلادلفيا في
منتصف فبراير الجاري
اثناء الاستجواب اوضح سعد الغريبي ان
المتهمه
طلبت من الوليد المساعده بنقل اغراضها
وعندما صعد معها الى غرفتها قامت بطعنه
ورنه في الحمام المشترك ثم سرقت اغراضه
فيما رفضت محكمه الافراج المؤقت عن كفاله
الماليه وطالبت باستمرار احتجازي هذا
الشرطه
على خلفيه قضيه الوثائق السريه افادت
وسائل الاعلام الامريكيه بان مكتبه
تحقيقات الفيدراليه الامريكيه الاف بي اي
فتشا منزل الرئيس جو بايدن في ديلر وفي
اول تعليق على الحادثه اوضح بوب باور
المحامي الشخصي للرئيس الامريكي انا وزاره
العدل نفذ التفتيشا مخططا الاهلي منزلي
بيض في ضلاوير صباح اليوم مضيفا بان بايد
ان يتعاونوا مع ذلك الاجراء وذكر باور في
بيان اتفقنا على التعاون مشيرا الى ان
النقابه سيكشف عن مزيد من المعلومات بعد
انتهاء التفتيح
بعد ما اختفت الشهر الماضي واثار اختفائها
ذعارا كبيرا اعلنت السلطات الاستراليه ان
خدمات الطوارئ عثرت على كبسوله صغيره مشعه
في ولايه غرب استراليا عمليه العطور على
هذه الكبسوله شبهتها وسائل الاعلام بانها
فعليا فعليه بحث عن ابره في كومه قش حيث
بدات عمليه بحث ضخمه عنها عندما فقدت
اثناء نقلها على طريق يمتد 1400 كيلومتر
عبر هذه الولايه فيما تكمن خطوره هذه
الكبسوله باحتوائها على كميه صغيره من
عنصر السيزيوم 137 الذي قد يتسبب في تلف
بالجلد او حروق اوعيه بسبب الاشعاع
في عمليه هي الاولى من نوعها فادت صحيفه
جلوبال تايمز الصينيه بان علماء اجرو
عمليه استنساخ ناجحه لبقره من سلاله عاليه
الانتاجيه والقادره على انتاج 18 طنا من
الحليب سنويا الصحيفه اوضحت ان علماء
جامعه الشمال الشرقي للزراعه والغابات
استنسخوا ثلاثه عجول عن طريق نقل نويات
الخلايا الجسديه واستخدموا في هذه العمليه
انسجه اذن الحيوانات مشينا الى ان تجربه
تبتسم باهميه كبيره بالنسبه لانعاش قطاع
تربيه الحيوانات في الصين التي تستورد في
الوقت الراهن نحو السبعين في المئه من
البقر المخصص لانتاج
وفي خبرنا الاخيره صحيفه وسط الجورنال ان
شركه جنرال اوتوماكس الامريكيه لصناعه
الاسلحه عرضت بيعه طائرات مسيره لاوكرانيا
بسعر زهيد للغايه الصحيفه اوضحت ان الشركه
قدمت اقتراحا الى ملحق الدفاع الاوكراني
في واشنطن ينص على بيع كل طائرتين من دون
طيار من طراز ريفر امبيو 9 مقابل الدولار
واحد فقط لمساعده الجيش الاوكراني لكن
الصفقه تتطلب من كياز انفاق نحو عشره
ملايين دولار لاعداد وشحن الطائرات الى
اوكرانيا ونحو ثمانيه ملايين دولار كل عام
لصيانه هذه الطائرات من دون طيار قديمه
والتي لا يتم استخدامها حاليا في اوكرانيا